with the holiday weekend getting
underway gas prices are climbing toward
the $3.00 mark for the first time in
four years regular gas is now going for
an average of two dollars and 96 cents a
gallon triple-a expects more than 41 and
a half million Americans will travel for
Memorial Day weekend that's up nearly
five percent from last year
Michelle Miller is on the road in New
Jersey Michelle good morning good
morning well the good news is that the
National gas price average is well below
the 2008 record of four dollars and 11
cents still the average American
household is expected to pay $200 more
this here on gas than they did last year
so that could keep some travelers off
the road this Memorial Day weekend
that's nothing we can do about it don't
have another choice sound like Apple
horse in the backyard as Americans gear
up for the start of summer rising gas
prices are tempering their excitement
I'm going to stay local as a result of
probably of the gas prices and just the
obscene amount of traffic that is gonna
be here this weekend according to
triple-a at least 16 states have hit an
average gas price of at least $3 a
gallon
one import gas stations in America are
selling gas at three dollars or more
that's about 50 cents more than this
time last year Jeanette Castle on ou is
a spokesperson for triple-a once we're
getting towards the 350 mark is when we
really see people making drastic changes
people may not travel as far or may not
travel nearly as long as they had
planned to or even while they're on
vacation they may not eat out as much or
pinch pennies in other ways so what's to
blame for America's problems at the pump
recent political unrest in oil-rich
countries like Iran and Venezuela are
just one of the reasons for the recent
price hike the sanctions on Iran will
take their oil out of the system and
Venezuela politically is a mess and it's
melting down economist Peter Muricy says
cuts in oil production and an increase
in consumer demand add to the squeeze on
wallets with gas prices so cheap the
last couple of years people have been
buying bigger vehicles and so it's going
to be hard to drive down gas
in consumption in the near term and so
that's contributing to rising prices
Triple A reports the lower costs for
airfare hotels and car rentals could
help ease those gas hikes and here's
some more silver lining to this tale
those prices at the pump could level off
by midsummer
Nora well that is a silver lining
Michelle thank you so much